The secret to gaining the upper hand in
negotiations is giving the other side
the illusion of control and the illusion
of control is typically best given with
either questions that begin with the
words what or how both what and how
should be the form of nearly any
question where you're trying to gather
information and it's actually one of the
ways we say no.
The first and best way to say no to
anyone is
how am I supposed to do that?
Now the other side actually has no idea.
Is it a number of things you've done
with them at the same time
you've conveyed to them you have a
problem.
Something that we also refer to as
forced empathy because one of the
reasons why we exercise tactical empathy
is because we want the other side to see
us fairly.
We want them to see our position.
We want them to see the issues we have.
We want them to see the constraints that
we have and when you say to somebody,
how am I supposed to do that?
You make them take a look at your
situation before they respond and they
think about it in a number of different
ways at a number of different people
I've coached with negotiations who have
felt completely helpless.
They felt completely taken hostage.
One instance where a woman thought she
was taken hostage to the future and she
just wasn't getting paid.
They called her up to give him more work
and we taught her to say,
trained or counseled her to say,
how am I supposed to do that?
They thought about it for awhile.
I said,
you're right.
You can't.
I've noticed that response is not word
for word directly responsive to her
question.
What they responded to was they felt
like.
She said to them,
I can't do this anymore.
I've reached my limit
and it's a way to establish a limit in a
way that doesn't back the other side
into a corner.
You're really want to be able to let out
no a little bit at a time,
and the first way to start letting out
no as an answer is,
how am I supposed to do that?
Now ultimately with that question,
we all imagine that the other side is
going to say,
because I said so,
because you have to.
That's actually where you ultimately
want to be with that question because
when you say how am I supposed to do
that,
and the other side says,
because if you want this deal,
you'll have to.
What you've just found out is they had
been pushed to the limit on that issue
as far as they'll go and the eternal
question is,
have I gotten everything I could on that
was on the table?
That's a great way to find out whether
or not you've gotten everything you on
that particular term because the other
side,
most angry responses because you have
to,
which is not them walking away.
It's not them terminating the deal.
It's not them giving you any more of an
ultimatum.
It's them saying,
no,
I've got no more room to give without
the negotiations breaking off.
So given the other side,
the illusion of control while signaling
limits,
it's a great way to stay in the
conversation and find out that you're
not leaving anything on the table.
It was coaching a real estate
negotiation recently and that the agent
was trying to lease a very expensive
home in the Hollywood hills and the
first time they said to the leasing
agent,
how are we supposed to do that?
The leasing agent relented on a number
of the terms conversation continued for
awhile.
They came to another term that was
pretty much almost an impasse and the
person doing the negotiation says that
how are we supposed to do that?
And the leasing agent said,
if you want the house,
you're going to have to do it.
Which was a confirmation that they've
gotten as much as it could have out of
that term.
So it's a great way to give the other
side the illusion of control because
what many people need to feel like
they're in control under negotiation and
when they feel like they're out of
control,
they're impossible to deal with.
So the more you let the other side feels
like they're in control,
the more amenable they are to
collaboration.
You really don't want people to feel out
of control.